aujourd'hui fab lesquin marches plus
haut après c'est pas très grave parce
que honnêtement ya pas grand chose à
voir non plus ce vide quand même mais
mais ça je sais pas pourquoi ça marche
pas je faut que j'essaye tête de prendre
mon téléphone ou quoi c'est pas
faux mais peut-être un bug avec les cas
main
mais on n'arrive pas à les mettre c'est
une heure
petrov petrov
on voit son va se mettre comme ça en
espérant qu'elles arrivent en fait
on va les laisser pour que dès que dès
que ça des bugs on le voit ce nom le
verra pas
mais un genre qui furent un aperçu de
personnes ont rien à [ __ ]
comme je les ai tous comme mon jeu
ils ont du
temps ça fait tout bogey
rica me font tous buggé fab
ah ouais ouais en tout cas ça marche pas
elle et qui ricanent font de gay de quoi
on parle pas si si là on parle
si les ont tous c'est bizarre je vais
demander si un truc messad
une raison pour laquelle c'est buggé
chier pas je vais demander
ont peut-être changé un truc qui m'ont
peut-être pas écrit
je vais demander bon en tout cas on en
est au deuxième coup
ouais ils ont changé toutes les gammes
bon ben je vais mettre la première ça
peut faire bugger le truc par contre les
amis
ça peut tout faire bugger fab
brice passe rien attendant donc sarah
s'écoule un
bon il a pris et l'a pris au caire au
genre des six
t'attends à quoi toi une turbo droit oui
oh non
jusque tout canalise je regarde du coup
sûr leur vidéo
attends attends tu entends changer la
camsa fait bugger 1
pourquoi est ce qu'elle n'apparaît pas
manquer en fait nous on voit qu'on l'a
vous voyez pas mais je la vois pas tant
ok c'est bon allez c'est bon ça et on al
hakam du concours switcher des maîtres
en grand ou regarde les chiffres pour en
avoir qu'une là du coup sinon ça à tout
faire mais je veux dire ah tu peux la
mettre en grève ouais ça on peut
normalement ça va marcher voilà ni
calmement dans notre set-up habituel le
sait très bien ouais
ouais bon ok bah des 6 et linguistique a
fléchi bas bon il va faire quelques
extras j'imagine il est jeté et c4 et
une partie contre caruana
à 12 ans il ya trois ans
et
je pense que oui de quoi on parle c'est
la petite finale non mais fait qu'il y
ait des trois t3 mais ça fait pas une
petite finale aussi aussi un peu inquiet
points du fait qu'il henry thoreau de
verdun meuse de même sac
af447 finale
mort est mon avis est que va ne veut pas
faire grand chose
j'ai une petite variante et puis je
pense qu'il épousera normalement il va
pas trop chercher à pousser comme un fou
bah si ce n'est pas fini dans une pièce
où je sais pas quoi bon bah il prendra
le point
d'avenir dit ses shoots bloquer le pion
central des oui c'est vrai mais le
cueille var bouger là je pensais faire 4
pour justement libère espions voilà
c'est fait et faire des 3 ou
des quatre
ça une impression bizarre quand même
cette partie avant l'impression que
c'est une partie sans enjeu entre
guillemets dans un tour anormal les
joueurs seraient mis d'accord pour faire
nul je pense
peut-être qu'ils ont fait quand même
parce que c'est ouais c'est un peu
[Musique]
bon match il a pour finir le travail
qu'on règle on va dire
non clairement mais je veux dire quoi
qu'il en soit dans le
comprends je veux en venir quoi
c'est parti parti sans réel enjeu là
maintenant et
les peaux qui va pas avoir très envie de
jouer
c'est très difficile de jouer la
tournée peau ça va vraiment être au loup
or malgré ses six dans cette opposition
j'ai agi
il dit
les dessins moquer des 100 watts à
menacer blanc c'est pas magnus qu'entre
caruana
j'ai pas fait ses valises
pour dire en fait la menace des blancs
s'étaient cahier des cinq qui
attaquaient la dame
était quatre caisses des cinq qui a aidé
quatre tubes ou flat d'un état d'âme
il y avait juste un piège peut-être me
montrer quoi pour c'est pas très malin
mais c'est ok qui ici si ce qui est des
cinq caïds et 4 est en fait là les
blancs pourrait croire gagnant avec dams
et 4
parce que tu dis ok juste à kadam cette
jeunesse est celle des attaques des
quatre j'attaque tout sauf que les
organes etc et c3
lesage avait vu en live ya trois ans
bref mon époux à part la petite élise
est de tijuana met donc dans la partie
je dire s'étaient pas passées comme sens
et qui sait si ce qui est des cinq qui
est des cartes des bouffées les dames
des jo de finale est
bon mon cas et si c'est aussi logique
hein c'est juste il évite la menace est
donc voilà la presse qu' il n'y change
des dames où nous fait un petit fou 3 ou
c3 pour pour défendre des 4
je pense qu'il va échanger
hamon va voir je suis curieux de savoir
s'il est mis avec une idée pour jouer
quand même pour gagner ou simon plus
rien il fait juste des nuls
mais à mon avis il va pas jouer une
nouveauté de froid et c'est pour ça que
je finis mais bon le truc c'est que les
9,40 coup il va jouer un peu et
puis et puis on verra
quand tu peux jouer 40 coups à jouer 40
coupe ah ouais
bon ok c'est 6 à peu près russie de
nouveaux thèmes comme ça je sais pas sa
source à transposer dans autre chose on
herald et noir prenaient dame prend
d'amundi et c6
bon ça je suis sûr qu il a déjà de
regarder vu que mon but c'est de cette
ligne entre fabiano
je veux dire bon si jamais répète qu'on
soit prêt à chanter à faire juste ces
trois pour le moment
on peut avoir un scénar et la brésil
allemagne aussi jack a
fait déjà vos allemagne
ça peut encore empirer pour les peaux
ça dépend plus de magnus en fait qu
autre chose
aussi n'est pas aussi il se ressaisit un
petit peu
géré ainsi magnus envie de gagner sydney
pour jour comme en début de match il
avait retenu cinq premières rondes aimé
ce qu'il a envie de gagner ça la
question ce qui n'a même pas envie on
sait pas en fait on sait pas
non mais
franchement je vous correctement un
[ __ ] je voulais un très bon niveau
c'est d'être correct depuis depuis
plusieurs jours
pas de raison que tout d'un coup il se
met à mal jouer
mais normal on t'a pas tous en vie dans
cette situation de match toujours un
truc comme ça non
et peut-être très fort ou pas je sais
pas l'année
non tu peux changer les dames tous les
ans est mort tu peux faire c'est 3
d'avoir peut-être inventaire de mon
problème je sais pas moi c'est pas mal
vraiment le titre du stream n'est pas
parti 10 écrits ou je sais pas quoi
j'ai juste un
ça va ils vont survivre
au second tour aucune chance de revenir
alors mathématiquement s'il ya des
chances mais c'est juste que c'est
tellement improbable voilà weight n 3
une chance sur cent mille peut-être
quelque chose comme ça je sais même pas
comment quantifier mais
c'est quand même si au foot il ya 4 0 à
la 78e minute tu peux mettre quatre buts
en douze minutes mais c'est très
improbable
il lui reste plus de deux fois les
blancs
et gris et puis non d'après ce match ce
qu'on voit plus ce n'est peut continuer
à être un joueur de premier plan que
rona ou un souvenir autre seigneur
dragon kayak in
bon wagon cela appartient jeu mon
feeling ce serait que ça dure pour lui
de se remettre
à ce que mon feeling n'ya pas
paris barça si c'est un nom il y avait
beaucoup plus de chance pour le barça de
m 6,5 de revenir là dans le match déjà
j'avais été fait dans les formes et déjà
plus de chance comme ça
alors là c'est vraiment
difficile à comparer ces
c'est du domaine de l'impossible went on
peut y aller 4-0 mi-temps oui mais non
c'est plus que ça en fait c'est plus le
cadre de mètres plus
bas c'est peut-être 6 0 ou 7 0 à la mi
temps mais je sais pas quand vous ici
en ce cas c'est vraiment dans le domaine
de l'impossible devient possible
et deuxième chose à dire c'est que
chaque exemple vous prenez ça marseille
qui remontera montpellier ou sans faire
injure à cette équipe du psg le barça
compte paris l'équipe qui semblait plus
forte à marseille qui est médicale à
domicile contre montpellier à l'époque
de marseille de courbis donc il y avait
du pire est avait du mal avec les gros
joueurs
le barça batave et le trio devant messi
neymar suarez ou quoi donc tu te dis bon
qui essaient juste quasi impossible même
si on a bien oui c'est vrai ça c'est
comme si ces dépôts qui venait 3 prévoit
la vie répond parce que 400 dates vont
enfin se réveiller tout déchirer mais
voilà dans l'autre sens on penserait
quand même c'est pas trop possible mais
voilà la
ccsa ces genres le real madrid qui a une
4-0 contre saint-etienne à 18 de la fin
des arrêts très bien dit
régis magnac bon tu as j'imagine mal le
synthé de mettre quatre buts pour
revenir
non là c'est vraiment
là c'est vraiment dans le domaine de
l'impossible après bien monde wigan bah
oui non
mais bon il ya peu de monde
ouais mais manchester bayern oui mata de
corner tu marque deux buts c'était
improbable mais ses pirouettes c'est
bien là bien peur là c'est vraiment pire
là
j'ai regardé un peu d'abord ils sont
dégoûtés ou non
en fait ils font comme beaucoup tu vois
je voyais un peu ce que ce qu on disait
dans le tchat
non ils sont notre mouiller le menu 6 3
mais bon il manque encore un point et
demi à magnus pour être champion ouais
c'était professionnels pour mettre les
point forts ils sont en mode comme ça et
tu vois je faisais quelqu'un qui sait
qu'ils allaient trouver le qui avaient
parié tout à l'heure dans le chat n'est
pas vraiment regardé le match championne
et qu'il regrette le regarder au travers
des vidéos récap de gotham
et oui c'est une chose d'être le match
vraiment très excitant et très
intéressant
raconte ce que tu veux en fait pas bonne
à dire oui il a six points mais il
manque encore un point et demi fabien il
faudra vraiment que manu serre le jeu
pour 20 peut-être dire que tu as dit
rien n'est moins sûr rien n'est moins
sûr et bon bah enfin oui tu peux dire ça
en fait si tu veux un
vrai je crois que de plus en plus les
gens sont plus intéressés par la vérité
en fait un tour contre une histoire
raconte une histoire et c'est vraiment
un très beau match très serré des
parties incroyable enfin gagné contre le
franc suisse 3-1 du neuf c'est un peu ça
si tu me dises à son à la suisse de se
qualifier
c'est peut-être même un peu pire sûr il
ya quand même trois des quatre essais
les échecs mais
oui franc suisse c'est quand même un
truc bizarre qui s'est passé je veux
dire
dans le cas
tu peux raconter ce que tu veux du match
mais à ses fins ce n'est pas une
mauvaise chose de le faire c'est ce que
les gens veulent après tu peux donner
aux gens ce qu'ils veulent ou tu peux
simplement c'est à matrix la pilule
bleue où la pilule rouge en fait tu vas
tu peux décider de donner aux gens ce
qu'ils veulent et c'est pas faim c'est
pas une critique en fait c'est c'est des
gens qui ce fait s'est adapté au monde
dans lequel on vit aujourd'hui en fait
c'est très bien enfin mais juste c'est
pas la réalité tu vas télé russie sont
un peu dans ce même truc là on est
peut-être parce qu'ils veulent pas
défoncer vraiment yann enfin on même
sens me défonce et a besoin d'être
méchant ou gentil avec lui j'ai juste
fait des rebonds baillif il était
dépassée dans ce match voilà c'est le
quart sans faute après dans l'interview
pour match tribu était très tranquille
continue
wikio bel avantage ou quoi il a dit oui
bon déjà faudrait réussir à réaliser les
avantages mais pour aider ou au moins
pas gaffer des pièces en un fouillis
serai déjà content d'arrêter de café en
un toit mais bon il n'avait pas l'air
abattu dans l'interview pour match tv
oui non lui il étaye son fardeau n'est
pas notre confiance je reviens et déjà
pas crâne immigrés se dire au moins tu
vois au minimum déjà arrêté de donner
des pièces en lin après on verra fin
c'est plus on verra genre ok on va
essayer de faire trois nuls et arrêter
de faire n'importe quoi
mais bon on est paul s'il est si
tranquille que des interviews qui est
passée des prix mais pour revenir à la
question de la galette à l'heure ça se
trouve il va juste reprendre le cours
normal de sa carrière après un non il
n'a pas semblé aussi déprimé que ça et
se dire bah écoute c'est la vie j'ai
appris et on verra une autre fois et je
lui soit 1 heure plutôt que de tuer
juste des primes est plus ferme et
comprendre que sa place dû ravir aux
cieux
mais ouais mais non j'ai vraiment passé
à côté de chaque côté 1
il a dit qu'il était déprimé ouais mais
enfin il ya dire que tu es des prix mais
il ya aussi la dans l'interview n'avait
pas l'air à savoir qu'il est dégoûté de
filet des pièces en un atout mais
n'était pas là se
mettait plus
qu'elle me choisir pour dire ça
résignés
sur ce match là mais tu avais l'art il
avait vu ça faisait arrêter des piastres
1 puis on verra après quoi donc c'est
peut-être après qu'il y avait pas de
rapport avec le match et c'est peut-être
fait pas ton rassurant mais tu as était
peut-être pas tant parce notre hymne
dans l'urgence après on voit mes joueurs
après on voit pas là et peut-être après
envoi aux comptes fin après plus
généralement et pas sur ce match
je suis juste n'est pas assez déprimée
j'ai vraiment l'impression qui n'est pas
motivé depuis début août j'ai envie de
dire tant mieux un
homme je pense qu'ils étaient motivés
jeudi après c'est étonnant de ne pas le
voir souvent assis à sa table après ce
pré sélection de comptoir je sais pas ça
se trouve c'est juste qu'ils supportent
pas d'être là qui se sent mieux là-bas
cacher loin du public des caméras et
tous les calculs sur son écran il
revient jouer je ne sais pas dur à dire
mais j'ai l'intimé conviction que d'être
très très motivés quand même tu gagnes
pas les candidats en sifflotant hier il
a travaillé comme un fou
et pour ce match il est venu avec un
nouveau répertoire est dur de changer
répertoire et ajoute toujours la même
chose toute ta vie et ça se voit qu il
le maîtrise sur la berthe war il a peut
être quand même les ouvertures il n'a
jamais été mal dans les ouvertures après
j'ai mal dans le jeu je me levant je
mens des fois tu prépares tous très bien
et puis bah tu joues mal qu'usman
mais est ce que tu vas voir là motif de
refaire les efforts de retravailler
nuitées jours a pas dire et je prends
soin mais bon en tout cas normalement
c'est quand tu te fais tout ce travail
là pour un match de championnat du monde
tu peux quand même temps c'est rare
quelques mois après tranquillement quoi
je veux dire s'il avait largement tourné
en février ou mars ou chez pac en
équivalence à petrov silva post affaire
réfuté du jour en main
les échecs c'est qu'un want is able les
arcs dure deux ans du coup tu as intérêt
à avoir un bon combat reste un peu sa
vie
c'est clark est très long pour pas grand
chose
il ya plein de il en avait ce matin on
dirait 3 4 messages un chat à ce propos
abba qui est envoyée lundi donc ça
devait arriver là on est mercredi
aujourd'hui je suis décalé
on est mercredi non
j'écoute ils sont partis lundi j'avais
entendu mais j'arrivais
réaliste et qui demande qu'on est sensé
3 [ __ ] d'un procès de ba ouais en fait
les noix en fait ils attaquent l'option
des 4 août après de te prendre qu'il
prend des quatre donc et battu doit le
défendre ou tu faire dame prend dames
d'abord si tu fais une menace plus forte
et puis on va plus tard
alors faut 3 c'est peut-être le meilleur
coup je sais même pas en fait à ce que
parce que tu prépares de bouger ton
kelly b 1 il fait grand acquis etc mais
bon la station de match quand même c'est
pas bien envie de plus voire dame de fer
une finale avec une potion symétrique et
d'assurer une position tu peux pas
perdre quoi
de son équipe et est catastrophique
l'espère pour une époque où ce regus et
foncer dans le mur rêve je sais par la
vue du match me demande si c'est pas
vraiment juste l' approche globale mais
ce qu'ils pouvaient faire mieux yann je
ne sais pas en fait réellement faire
mieux il s'est enfermé dans ces
espagnols oui mais en fait il n'a pas
perdu dans les ouvertures non plus
en fait elle n'a pas trouvé un coup du
match en fait il n'a pas trouvé de coûts
la combière b4 ou c4 le toit ou le dom
g7 g5 à partir de 20 du plein de petits
moments où
je ne vais pas une position gagnante
pour autant mais il fait pas et l'autre
y perd aussi vous grand b 4 ou
le four b2 il faut cinq fois il ya plein
de coups quoi et c'est dommage il a raté
tous ces moments là on ayant globalement
un niveau de jeu correct mais pas le bon
coup au bon moment juste quelques
craquage de cartes sont exploités ça par
contre et bah voilà
non non c'est du coup c'est difficile à
savoir où est ce qu'il a vraiment perdu
le match s'ils avaient vraiment
possibilité de le gagner au final
mais c'est peut-être fusent dans la
proche après peut-être une autre
ouverture aurait donné une autre
approche aussi essorée oui serré les
choses différemment mais
met clairement dans les ouvertures il a
même été mieux finir égal avec les bleus
n 6 a pas mal l'ouverture en soit il
n'était pas si mal et avec les noirs y
la star est plutôt bien sorti
les prochains terrifié pour les
candidats donc ben n'est pas on va dire
faby fierro exactement ta radjabov aussi
derrière green bout d'un quart à kindu
da est là et il en manque deux
autres
plateau pour les candidats
sûrement
jeudi rebond l'an dernier par il faut
pas faire offense faite avait un alex
king co tu te dis bon tant mieux pour
lui d'être là mais c'est pas un joueur
tu attends et wang hao non plus et là
pour l'instant les six déjà qualifiée
sans top 15 mondiaux en plus je sais pas
et les deux prochains bas pour gagner
des grands prix je pense que ça sera
qu'un détour en quoi c'est tout là y'a
que des fins il ya que des bons il ya
beaucoup de bons dans la maxime
ratzinger à
guérir à wesley so au bâti et rabat
quillorama mais sûrement c'est sûrement
d'envoi et après tu peux te voir une
surprise mais ça peut être avec misty
pink co
mais voilà que ça ferait
ça peut ça t'arrive au contingent comme
ça mais oui elle par mme ding ding saïfi
ça peut être beau avec mpl wake pâquis
où elle devait l'évacuer dans le chatt
leur agricole aussi je pense ouais oui
oui donc ça peut être un candidat y
performent
comme la plupart des candidats toujours
fort mais voilà le dernier je veux dire
tu te dis tiens si on remplace
[Musique]
six ans remplace fonds bio par sohu
ericsson co par jacky qui
m'aimait pas c'est peut être ma musique
funèbre enfin
peu importe en fait avec maïwenn pour
qu'on a un nom
que tu as bien disent oh bah j'ai dit
sur eux voient le deuxième ne peut pas
savoir
parce qu'on peut avoir radio internet
voilà rate la balle du coup
ricard ou
à
du coup du coup et c'est vrai mais
c'était c'était un peu une
une exception ses candidats oui bien sûr
en réalité mais toujours très fort et là
ça peut vraiment être un plateau
incroyable avec quasiment tout le monde
ça réfléchit côté magnus
en fait il doit être tiraillé entre le
fou ou trois qui doit être meilleure
et la dame prend 1,7 qui est plus
pleutres mais dans ce match il a quand
même joué le coup le plus pleutre
éclairé dès qu'il l'a pu ouais donc je
pense qu'il va continuer à être un
pleutre éclairer un ça va bien aussi de
faire le tri klein
shell doit être qualificatif aux
candidats
c'est 3 et pleutre éclairer un
logique
je pense que néo pop heureux gaffé une
pièce aujourd'hui
parfaite vu ce qu'il a fait hier j'en ai
te dire oui mais bon je sais pas des
gens
mais il peut d'ailleurs on n'imaginait
pas qu'ils puissent gaffe est dans une
position bien ce truc deux tours avec un
bien fou quoi
et pourtant
donc
[Musique]
ça sent la bonne purge cette partie
quand même
ça sent la partie de l'eau merde
si vous avez quelque chose à faire les
amis cet après midi fait le
jetez pas bloquer ces ne restez pas
bloqué il va normalement il devrait rien
même s'il se passe quelque chose sera
pas vraiment d'impact alors en plus il
devrait rien se passer
n'hésitez pas n'hésitez surtout pas à
avoir une journée constructive parce que
la partie peut être longue
genre vraiment vous appelle peut durer
plusieurs heures un bal devrait durer
puce devrait durer plusieurs heures il
devrait rien se passer et même s'il se
passe quelque chose de toute façon c'est
rien donc j'ai envie de dire
enfin mcafee se soit passé trois fois 6
heures à casser les pubs et turbo drogba
n'ont fait on est obligé ça c'est une
chose mais si c'est l'occasion de faire
autre chose de votre journée bon vous
pouvez nous les laisser en font parce
que vous avez bien nous nous écouter ça
c'est une autre chose et on passe
l'après midi ensemble ça c'est cool mais
ne restez pas figé devant l'écran
alors des signes qu aux logiques un
quelque part il reprend l'espace
certaines rumeurs parlent de triche dans
la salle de repos un avis à wil hahn et
poney peau ça c'est ça se voit vraiment
il a simplement
miser une aide extérieure pendant tout
le match c'est ce qui explique
d'ailleurs c'est magnifique partie aux
fab emile a bien caché il a très bien
caché tricheurs intelligent très
intelligente infolab on vous le fond
l'attrapera de là mais
carlos 14 qui me touche par le synthé
voyage pas trop quoi dire c'est un peu
le branle bas de combat au club vont
virer l'entraîneur l'adjoint est reparti
dans le monde le directeur du
recrutement il doit partir aussi
ça va rebâtir dans l'urgence et puis
j'espère qu'on fera une bonne pioche
quelqu'un qui va nous faire si beau mois
pour maintenir le club peut être une
petite revente qu'on a un petit mercato
hivernal qui te permettent quand même de
recruter 2 3 de travail solide mais
voilà j'ai vu à michel salgado arrive
pas peut-être peut-être seul gallo qui a
d'ailleurs fait un coup d'envoi d'une
partie
et à dubaï allez ça sent pas la bonne
recrue
non mais il vient avec des roses coffre
pour reprendre le pas si c'est lui un
c'est une des pistes
ça finir en coupe davis cosmos cette
histoire ça sent pas bon fab
essaie de se rassurer bayer ud5 j'ai vu
un petit des cimes causé bien voilà donc
une pour sainté durera dix ans vers la
prochaine traînards qui sait et
non pas terrible et gros danger
maintenant pour la radiation jadis après
grâce à jordan de fous de foot et 6
3 attention un piège
un briquet fera je me fait jouer dira
joueurs cavalier sans tête
des 3 6 6
et change
des lieux 5 5
une belle partie comme ça
huit des trente et des trois essais très
bien joué pour enquête prend 4 f troquer
des six ans alors oui est ce que ça peut
faire des erreurs faisait feu
cinq ou six tours des infos être bien
sûr
bref c'est alors ce genre de choses
c'est possible ou pas
de la drogue mais là ok j'ai trois
encore pour h théâtre et tu voudras fta
le fond ouais mais tu prends pas les
normes bien comme il faut bien
mais oui ça serait magnifique
scénario qui peut arriver après avec les
blancs si manu ce sens de la jouer
longtemps pour marquer un point de plus
et finir puis vite il peut essayer de
l'après sauter ou pas mais
est ce que tu penses que dans les années
à venir on pourrait avoir un cycle
parallèle de championnat du monde
d'échecs rapide
que tu penses ce serait possible d'avoir
enfin une bonne réponse ça serait
possible mais on va le faire enfin je
sais ils vont regarder leurs trucs
championne du monde rapide sur deux
jours pourquoi pourquoi pas en fait ben
je sais pas qui définit
en fait c'est ça le problème depuis le
début bah oui c'est quoi c'est pas toi
qui décides au les amis je crois qu'on a
trouvé le problème aussi c'était femme
qui décide et on se met très très très
bien et du coup c'est pas toi qui
chapeaute le truc du chapeau très
malheureusement aïe aïe aïe
c'est pas toi qui chapote non mais du
coup peut-être commence à dominer
un truc que c'était toi qui chapeautait
à mon avis on serait très bien
c'est en vrai est ce que tu es d'accord
ainsi que le parallèle parallèle en
rapide avec des candidats rapide un
match au final du monde rapide tu fais
la même chose rapide ouais c'est pas mal
et en plus tu pourrais le faire tous
d'affilée
ouais car tu es candidat rapidement
prendre trois jours ça va pas arriver
éreinté hommage au champion du monde
deux jours après après remarques tu
pourrais faire un système coupe à 8 à la
fin ouais ouais tous les villages ça
peut aller vite ça t'as pas besoin et
que ça dure
j'ai pas content non je peux te faire
1,6 par an
c'est pas mal un tapis statues les
échecs normaux je pense non en fait
moralité c'est pas du tout tu as les
échecs normaux âmes faut faire très
attention l'idée c'est de faire ainsi
que parallèle et après on voit ce que
les gens préfèrent on ne met plus en
avant peut-être ce sera les échecs
classique
dans très probablement ce sera l'échec
classique dans tenter le coup ce qu'on
fait si tu leur dis que les gens ont
préféré les rapides ils vont surtout pas
essayer je pense vraiment un discours
fagan vis-à-vis de la fidh tenter les
rapides comme ça le plus probable c'est
que ça marchera moins bien c'est juste
pour essayer au moins il tient serré on
va essayer ça prouvera que le rapide
servant de la mer à merde on s'est
trompé
si on leur dit que les gens préfèrent le
rapide ils le feront jamais donc faut
leur faire croire que c'est bien pour
bien leur montrer c'est vraiment pour
prouver que les quelques contestataires
pour être bien sûr que les gens n'aiment
pas non mais tu peux vraiment faire un
sikh parallèle et et voilà on pensait
peut-être une fois tous les deux ans et
demi
donc et peut-être faire un cycle
parallèle par correspondance aussi
médias oui messieurs les vraiment très
dangereux les parties sont beaucoup plus
longues les gens vont vraiment aimer
encore plus donc attention sa preuve
remplacer c'est beaucoup plus sécurisant
de tenter le rapide quitte à tenter
quelque chose pour vraiment vraiment
être bien sûr
mais je sais franchement je sais pas il
pourrait faire pour l'instant ils aiment
leur format comme ça mais c'est pas con
c'est tellement dommage que champion du
monde rapide qui a vu le truc le plus
hype en de la saison dure trois jours et
après bizarre ans qu'il a essayé de
faire un peu qu un compte chez ce tour
d'affaires un format rapide format long
un peu un mix des deux tests ont finale
où les 200 boîtes c'est pas mal c'est
pas idiot après ouais c'est pas vraiment
réussi à faire prendre le train
peut-être moins format qui était trop
fermé je sais quand même à lui réussi à
faire un accord avec la fia et faire de
ça un championnat du monde rapide avec
un circuit un machin truc way
coupe du monde est bien aussi basse et
voix du monde cerveau tourne ouais et
coupe du monde c'est cool ça en vrai
c'est cool mais bon on entrait ce format
là c'est juste bien pour garder le titre
de champion du monde quand même
ça perpétue un peu le truc mais on peut
essayer un peu de trouver une meilleure
façon de le faire
en fait tu peux faire les deux en
parallèle et voir et puis réellement
sans or troll à prévoir un peu les
points positifs des points négatifs tête
après les fusionner
les endroits où il ya un match non tous
les deux ans ferme deux 2 2 circuits
parallèles ça paraît pas insurmontable
non c'est pas toi sur la table c'est
juste qu'à tel endroit privé mais au
pire après georges choisiront rivés sur
vous pour un titre un peu tu vas être
non plus et a de l'argent on associe en
vrai un match championnat du monde
rapide je suis sûr que tu trouves plus
de fric que pour un truc privé 1 pour
les joueurs en vrai ça je sais pas enfin
sur le papier tu dis oui c'est un titre
de champion du monde et c'est la fidh
qui met son tampon de supporter le
certifier donc
vraiment je trouve des millions pour un
grand suisse
finale de championnat du monde rapide tu
dois pouvoir quand même c'est sympa fin
en soi c'est sympa un truc coûta au
début huit joueurs quarts de finale
lundi mardi demi finale c'est un super g
jeudi et finale semaine c'est que
les otages si peut-être juste regrouper
les candidats finale le problème c'est
que les simon entre les deux c'est juste
pour le candidat qui est temps de
préparer quoi et il fera en tout cas aux
candidats
les gagne bon bah si j'ai dans la foulée
tu dis est arrivé à la langue pendante
il faut rejouer partie de 8h15 scène
mais va pas tenir le gars qui que ce
soit donc même si moi je vais passer en
fait j'ai quand même mis un audio
bonhomme mais c'est vrai que si tu étais
un championnat du monde tous les ans
rapide c'est dommage parce que ça que ce
qui serait détournée au foot d'ailleurs
moi je suis contre la ligue des
champions tous les ans commises et la
coupe du monde tous les ans du coup ça
baisse là
ça augmente la valeur d'un titre de
champion du monde moi je pense au foot
aussi devrait faire une ligue des
champions une fois tous les deux ans tu
fais une saison blanche tu souffles du
souffle et une valise ligue des
champions tous les deux ans bon tu as eu
les ans avec des champions comme ça le
celui qui gagne ligue des champions a
bien fait il s'installe quand patron en
patron ça pour beaucoup de sports
collectifs font cette erreur d'avoir les
trucs chaque élu chaque année ouais tu
as le rugby pareil avec bouquet
toikeusse tous les ans non là je n'ai
pas encore à s'essouffler de la saison
précédente de rugby j'aurai besoin de
bien souffler cette année deux 2 ans tu
sais pas trop approché de moi je
mettrais 4 comme le foot - tu souffles
en mai - enfin moi par contre le foot
vaut un autre j'espère qu'ils vont bien
garder le rythme de 4,1 des coupes du
monde mais c'est différent mais la
multinationale
nationale n'a aucun rapport mais
nous aimons tous les deux ans au foot ce
serait comme ça je suis d'accord mais
bon c'est deux choses c'est comme si
roland garros tous les jantes a bien
soufflé de roland garros son dernier
souffle tous les quatre ont atteint
leurs alliés roland garros mais c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui vit tu sais
c'est roland garros
allenby et tous les cinq ans est
vraiment besoin de six mois pour se
préparer en vrai oui mais en plus c'est
peut-être même pas je rigole pas
honnêtement je disais salah un arabe
c'est à dire bon six mois ça va tu as le
temps de la transition mais peut-être
que tu y serait une année alors tu fais
du candidat au printemps et j'emprunte
en 2021 je faisais du monde pour un
temps donné le 22 bon teint en quoi j'ai
pas sûr que les gens ont compris que je
troll et ya plein de gens qui disent oui
non la ligue des champions tous les ans
c'est très bien c'était du troll en fait
c'est complètement stupide d'après moi
de la mettre une fois tous les deux ans
vient donc en plus c'est une énorme
différence ligue des champions tous les
ans et tous les deux ans là juste pour
rebondir à sa raison sur le truc et l
être des équipes de finale c'est qu'en
fait tu as ton équipe s'entraîne tous
les jours ensemble ah oui et c'est pas
pareil que quand tu fais des équipes
nationales août à rassemblement voilà
mais
ça que ça devrait vous mettre une
pancarte second degré quand tu fais bah
voilà ça se voyait que c'est du second
degré non je ne sais pas
c'était dur d'être sérieux là dessus un
nom mais en fait c'est juste série
d'histoires individuelles c'est tout un
normalement c'est tous les ans pas
un cycle sur l'année mais là du coup
pour la peine l'histoire du championnat
du monde rapide c'est qu'on pourrait
imaginer s'ils veulent garder ce truc
tous les deux ans qui me paraît moins
saugrenue mais on pourrait
on
pourrait faire une année le cycle rapide
et une année le cycle l'on en fait et du
coup tu gardes une fois tous les cinq
ans et le rapide
pour la peine comme l'euro et la coupe
du monde en gros mois de rang beaucoup
plus rapide mais là tu pourrais tu
pourrais le faire comme ça aussi ouais
ok cavaliers avec 3 yards à me prend je
pensais dame prend je prends cavaliers 6
jouer cavalier aussi sky prend ainsi
magnus et ses potes qui prendra part
dans l'univers food et si sur la fin je
veux dire ici sous des
basses arrêt petit rock petit rock avait
lui aussi ses chances je pense qu'il
parte pour turbo drôle un
nom le vent venir robin
une compétition tous les deux ans qu'ils
ont chacune sans qu'on peut être une
grave erreur on oublie la pub on a
oublié la pub une vraie femme on est mou
jours à tuer pas comblé les basiques
baru des pubs de trois minutes qui par
année paire lucie classique années
impaires le sic rapide et si les
champions sont différents le champion
d'une cadence qualifier automatiquement
pour les candidats de notre cadence très
bonne idée du lien balle d'ailleurs aux
faux il pourrait mériter un vip à tout
moment très intelligent le frérot ah ça
c'est malin ça c'est rare de il
malheureusement il ya la pub il a pas pu
entendre qu'on disait que c'était bien
je lui mettre plus sain je vais mettre
bravo belle idée je lui ai écrit quand
même parce qu'on sait pas si longtemps
c'est tellement rare qu'on ait les
bonnes idées du chat
curé hausse le niveau niveau du chat
non mais c'est vrai que c'est une bonne
idée 2
franchement c'est beau
[Musique]
par sûr turbo droit ou pas ouais
probablement là ça devient très probable
voyez plus les dames 2 et puis ces
positions de française des changes tout
symétrique sur broadway sq
donc pour avoir un truc sympa mais
là ça va turbo non
c'est pas ça serait bien mais
on est d'accord que la pression elle est
vraiment quasi égale femmes c'est un
tout petit plus pour les blancs en repli
du fait du cavaly des trois quarts et
lieu sinko non mais je ne sais pas c'est
rien par le vol qf6 tu feras f6 mais bon
est ce qu'il ya un chocolat chaud qui
par ce site turbo d'euros ouais avec
peut-être un peu d 'euros elle joue elle
m'a fait le sécateur savent qu'on envoie
le mafé noah
même peut-être demain
à l'église et
bad est déjà allée manger de ma fait non
ouais nous non plus on découvre très
bien quoi
c'est un tricheur et 9 euros par mois ça
arrive toutes les pubs sur tout les
channels a c'est vrai que c'est pas mal
tweets sur hbo
déjà l turbo ii dans son bord d'autres
votre which
[Musique]
ces génies coûteux vendre des trucs à
fond de basses et pour fureur de
ses biens non mais vraiment
et c'est tous les mecs même pareil pour
youtube qui me disait 4 occupe sur
youtube et ukrainiens bref toutes les
plus de trouille ou tubes
d'un jour au bout d'un moment c'est
normal fin gerta de la pub surtout les
toutes les choses gratuites donc c'est
bien qu'ils aient une manne manière de
l'enlever enfin moi je trouve ça bien
9 euros ce quand même super cher ben moi
je trouve pas mais après
un heads ou netflix hénaff euros par
mois
oui c'est pour regarder quelque chose à
la twee là tu te payes pour ne pas
regarder que rien mais la switch banon
et à toutes les chaînes twitch oui mais
t'es pas abonnée aux jeunes tout le
temps tu peux y aller oui mais tata tata
baptisé mode côté teman très bien oui
mais enlève la pub c'est pas bien
la pub valeurs netflix n'a pas pu parce
que c'est payant et gratuit
fotochat champion du monde de beach à nu
les kazakhs ont réduit apparemment
ça peut être un peu au chat mais
attention mais du coup le rapido 6 1
abbas était devenu enfin la cata quoi le
seul événement bien qu'ils arrivent à la
fin de l'année annuler ados quoi
je suis deg si c'est le cas j'étais
tellement content
tu sais pas où est ce qu'on peut voir
s'il faut en croire la poisse fi des
points comme le tien g20 juste comme ça
arrive même plus à faire un event un
championnat du monde
d'autres firmes et non mais faye et lien
ou feignant ouais il faudra bien un truc
ouais ouais lien au ban des fins
non mais c'est normal une info comme ça
ces liens ou band of
bonjour rien feed monseigneur qingdao
sinon
parlant de thiézac nom et d'ouzbeks des
braquages culte est ok si ses réacteurs
à kech rakach connaît
c'est dommage au tournoi mais bon après
oui c'est vrai que la période
[Musique]
des frontières qui ferment
coincer avec des trucs comme ça
oh la la les mauvaises nouvelles qui
s'enchaînent on la cache donc pas ban
à nice qui demande la source quand même
evian
un même guéri les parcours à nouveau
posée beaucoup plus légères par là que
ça va le chat est là quand même pour
pour donner les bonnes infos
mais je sais pas quelle est sa source
mais mon normalement c'est pas un idiot
heures à cache quelqu'un il écrit pas
n'importe quoi en fait
je vais même source or fake
or banda forman d'affaires
mais il a du jus store qui ne l'ont pas
rauf qui est pas content aussi
ils ont dû prendre leur billet d'avion
ils ont dû faire leurs visages c'est
n'importe quoi cinq sets en quinze mois
sans qu'un jour un
à dix sept braquages qu'il va pas écrire
si c'est fake et robbins a une confiance
du côté de chaises comme ça des infos
eau la catastrophe sur slate jazz comme
ils peuvent avoir des infos pour ces
trucs là ouais ok confirme ou pas
confiance je sais pas pas tout à fait
confirmé alexandre
[Musique]
sait pas encore mais ça semble
ok c'est pas officier c'est en cours de
[Musique]
c'est pas officielle mais amelia des
sources
j'ai envie de dire c'est des sources
anonymes concordantes
ballester rakach la vie de façon c'est
pas n'importe quoi et
peuvent pas déplacer le lieu à bala ça
me parait courant puisque le pakistan
pour se porter candidat non trop je vais
l'être pour changer votre fort mal de
matchs déjà à fond on discutera le
pakistan ne discute pas le pakistan
impose
dans la fidh n'est pas reconnue au
pakistan 1
la fédération pakistanaise des échecs
n'est pas affiliée à la fidh on n'a pas
envoyé des cris au championnat d'europe
aux olympiades pour beaucoup
mais elle est peu de la fédération ne
reconnais pas le bail qui semble ne
connaît pas la file de théâtre à jour ça
serait possible peut-être mais alors l
actuel non non
en europe le pakistan l'europe est dans
le pakistan fait c'est le même
nom mais là franchement le truc
le truc du kazakhstan c'est quand même
incroyable
annulé trois semaines avant enfin j'en
ai le sait même pas 3 seulement c'est
vraiment 17 jours avant on est le sport
le plus con du monde fab
et y en a aujourd'hui je sais lui
décembre mais ça c'est pas sûr à cannes
puisque moi vers sainte et à lyon aussi
c'est la fête des lumières je sais moi
des petites bougies au final est ici
plutôt que
ça va c'est joli que j'aimais millions
celle des lumières et du coup je suis
très triste j'ai sorti la veille apanui
aucune lumière de rien je te lave
et sa lumière on a saisi le solaire
c'est pas paris la ville des lumières
dont je pense que c'est lyon les frères
lumière
je sais pas s'il y en a eu des lumières
des frères lumière et sur lyonnais le
frérot il a supprimé son tweet
au le pleutre
du coup capture écran quoi je capture
écran d'un homme
s'est pas officiellement encore
bon ça turbo échangeant les gars si on
vous parle pas de la partie c'est que là
le clin d'oeil et partir
j'ai une question je suis 2200 santé
l'office j'ai un nom de stagner vous
avez une astuce
vous fait partie rapide tu verras vite
main mais en vrais pas ceux dépend quel
âge tu apprends un entraîneur en vrai
une vraie un vrai conseil va oui
justement ces caches tu as quel est ton
objectif le temps que tu peux y
consacrer
ça peut être beaucoup de calculs aussi
faut que tu fasses
est normalement en fait un bon truc
c'est que
si tu travailles dans le travail paye
quoi un petit peu pas donc après les
échecs des fois c'est ça stagne c'est
des escaliers quoi l'approbation donc
pendant un moment du risque peut-être de
ne pas trop bouger j'ai 16 ans à 16 ans
à un an tu peux tu peux être débloqués
mais ouais là prendre un entraîneur mais
tu vois là tu peux rester un palier un
palier en palier puis un an taf vient
tuer en marche un corner tout ça peut
être pas mal
parfois ça mais bon si tu ta région où
tu habites à quelqu'un à proximité près
évidemment tu trouvé sur internet tu as
même plus besoin de quelqu'un à côté
mais aussi d'avoir des courants réel
c'est assez sympa aussi pour l'aspect
humain et voilà partager des trucs mais
meiway peut-être entraîneur ça peu
après devant les objectifs ainsi faire
tes études ce devenir joueur ou plutôt
preuve d'échec ça dépend vraiment ce que
tu veux aussi un ouais
très beau quatuor en cours avec ladite
apprend la prise en passant c'est je
pense vraiment que je peux te débloquer
avec cette technique tu sais à ce niveau
à ce niveau beaucoup ont progressé quand
le pion et ans à 4 s'il pousse tu peux
prendre
c'est important la semaine d'arrêt oui
tu sais il y a le petit rock se permet
de bouger le roi est là tout en un seul
coup c'est vraiment un coup très malin
j'ai trois en train de faire piéger de
ff iv
reste qu'un hyper concentré
il adore ce plan j'ai l'impression de
remettre des
tifs ça
fait plaisir
surtout il aime ça
c'est ça le plus important ce serait
beau qu'il fasse j-6 voilà je crois
qu'il va dépasser 8 du vert feuillage 5
mathieu y en ait beaucoup
kg cet effet je trouve aussi je sais
faire
d'après nokia e7 seront qualifiés à
travers
ces six là à voir en fait mais pas
peut-être le temps fou des deux c6
et j'ai soif 5
je t'attends juste à temps
j'avais un avis sur l'iss deux eaux à
skis en finale à très bon livre mais il
faut un certain niveau pour le lire
et c'est long à lire
aujourd'hui 600 lots je me permets de me
moquer dans l'académie 780 comment faire
pour me soigner avant ne te soigne pas
tu as bien raison tu as bien raison bah
oui
1800 fixité bon pédagogue bien sûr que
[Musique]
moi je pense 1800 fit c'est un peu
faible pour être prof d'échec est
l'initiateur mes profs d'échec
ils vont se taper le prof apprendre les
règles et les bases et commencer une
partie pas mal
après je ne sais pas il ya des joueurs
en 1800 pour un bagage qu'on était plus
savants qui ont perdu leur point mais
qui ont une expérience etc je sais pas
jusqu'à quel niveau on sait enfin plein
de choses
jamais ils gagnent sur les quais noirs
les chansons de combien base 0,1 pour
cent s'ils gagnent aujourd'hui après on
revient aux 0,1 elle fait j 6
mai pour les finales et conseillers ben
moi je les conseiller dans mon petit
article où je conseille pas mal de
livres vous pouvez trouver sur ma chaîne
twitch en dessous vous avez des conseils
dit oui moi je les aime bien ce livre
pour livre de thin man pour les gens qui
veulent apprendre seul et qui commence à
vouloir apprendre les finales je trouve
vraiment bien foutu ça bon livre pour
apprendre seul
après on peut enfin avoir mis la vivre
des échecs en vendant des échiquiers par
exemple on pense à un certain etienne
paquereau
bien connu dans le milieu des échecs
office security please arizona
mais avec ça on va on va faire une
petite série de vidéos si on se trouve
le temps tous les deux c'est de faire
quelque chose de live je peux plus le
voir en dessous 2003
non mais il vaut beaucoup mieux
prennent en main et face à un coaching
du comics harnes quoi
je peux plus voir avant dessous de milly
bien sûr les lives et où on puisse y
comprend en fait c'est que des erreurs
tactiques je suis sûr que c'est que des
conneries de comme ces cinq de l'époque
ouais
ah c'est vrai que j'aurais bien aimé
pouvoir faire ça plus tôt et tout mais
juste la période a été tellement chargé
au tournoi là depuis un bon moment et
puis après en septembre j'ai mes trucs
un peu perso faisait que mais depuis
septembre en fait il ya plein de choses
qui n'ont pas été possible
donc h56 frais d'obsèques
et f4
bon ça me fout là partout mais c'est
vrai on aurait préféré que ça se passe
comme ça on doit faire ses six d'abord
nous fait un petit footing j'imagine
peut-être l'échangé
dégage le fou
non mais je ne veux pas faire exactement
ce qu'on voulait faire si facilement pas
c'est pas grave mais
j'essaie de regarder un petit truc à te
faire f 3 g 4 oui on se prête pas trop
trop
dans sur une position je sais pas
comment prendre l'espace à l d'amour
battu clic 1 à 4 à 5 b 4-1 bon
normalement l'autre va te faire la
symétrie en photo jeffrey catz face à un
équipe
oui mon bon l eelam away ce
mais c'est pion b qui peut être
problématique j'en refais rb5 avec les
noirs c'est sûr que c'est qu'on s'est
affaibli a cassé s'inquiète kiev 4 one
here en t3 mais on sait 5,05 et à quel
point arrière et c6 non faut pas pousser
les pions n'importe comment quand même
hein
alors le bouquin de kars annulaire
fondamentale chasse endings il est
recommandé par carson est aussi
recommandé par mois quand même avant
toute chose avant cette chose
mais ça fait trois ans que leurs
commandes ce livre ou quatre de ces
complémentaires ou c'est l'un ou l'autre
avec le vote requis
complémentaires je lisais les deux j'ai
eu les deux complémentaires les deux
sont bien
les partis en lice va vous faire
régresser au début pas vraiment
régresser scam un grand mot
non tu vas pas régresser après ceux de
franck faire prendre de mauvais réflexes
tu joues en partie longue que tu as
envie de jouer vite trop vite pas
prendre le temps
pas dicter envie de jouer en partie
longue un jour dans la vie après je sais
pas c'est un jour tourner enfin voici
comment ces déchets qui commence après
le truc c'est qu'au début justement
comme si tu débutes tu vois pas encore
plein de trucs et je vais à taux plein
d'idées de calcul extraordinaire c'était
un peu plus de temps peut tuer des
parties de dix minutes de mettre un peu
mieux que de finir à être en panique a
donné trop de cliquer au hasard
il a fait tout rue89 30
et court sur chasses sable sont bons ou
cher pour ce que c'est banon n'aime pas
trop de chasse chez sablon vrai mais bon
après c'est un goût personnel de
plusieurs trucs sur un talent et les
vidéos donc ça c'est peut-être ce cas
mieux mais en fait d'apprendre des
livres parker en faisant le module
je pense c'est juste apprendre par coeur
sans chercher à comprendre et à vue
cherche à restituer ce que tu as fais ce
que tu as vu je sais pas ce qu'on serait
une bonne méthode
après quand regarder des vidéos de
forgeard qui parle d'une ouverture bassa
pourquoi pas hein après ça dépend si tu
préfères le format vidéo ou livres ou
quoi après évidemment ça a un coût c'est
clairement beaucoup plus cher qu'un
livre
je préfère les vidéos
donc tu le sens
mais ils ont le module ou juste apprend
turc l'x compte à ce que tu as déjà vu
et tu dois faire 15 fois pour qu'il soit
validé je sais pas ça moi ça me parle
pas quoi
damas non plus ça me parle pas
mais en vrai les vidéos de chaises comme
sont vraiment bien allez petit cours
ouais bah même pas les vidéos
globalement mes petits courts sont bien
mais c'est l'équivalent des fins
l'équivalent c'est différent mais en
fait chez sable les vidéos doivent être
bien aussi mais c'est je vous parle
vraiment du module d'entraînement de
répéter du parc à redon moi j'aime pas
du tout non plus
ycare en sueur à cause du tout mais je
crois que tout le monde su à cause de ce
tweet mais votre personne ça c'est vrai
il ya pas de source
[Musique]
c'est sa
famille je suis tombé cette vidéo sur
chaise comme jeu facile à une
kalachnikov on peut la prendre à
n'importe quel niveau je regarde la
première série et j'aime bien la
position aux barres oui un super thème
la
wes qu'une petite vidéo séries
pas mal pour s'y mettre et
ça c'est correct et cohérent et tu peux
après le seul truc c'est que si tu joues
la sicilienne on savait donc je parle
pas je parle que de la kalachnikov dans
le dos de série mais tu vas avoir à
faire à plein de ce variant tons que ce
soit les rosso l'immoler key ces trois
anciennes fermes et les a lapidés camby
mort à tata grand prix
voilà vous faut aussi faire un boulot à
côté
mais pour l'utmb style est ouverte
je pense juste à casser cette vidéo ou
quoi tu peux vraiment la joue et je
pense jusqu'à un niveau largement à plus
de 2000 c'est bon quoi
d'ailleurs sur la tacc baudelaire on a
fait une vidéo sur la chaîne youtube
ouais ouais que j'étais attendu
apparemment d'après la première réaction
est
très bien en faire d'autres à l'occasion
on verra mais c'est vrai qu'il se fout
c4 dans sicilienne c'est bien de voir
qu'on lutter contré pas dû ouvrir la
diagonale en tout cas
ça c'est drôle direct
le parti a pas grand intérêt et un
bar
à petit cube à harbin de passage pour
récupérer 6 allée récup on n'a pas tout
de suite ensuite les actes
les amis on est de retour pour la suite
la suite de ce palpitant deux parties
ça est vraiment extraordinaire
aujourd'hui pour la paix la partie
avec donc le cavalier qui vend h5
prolong pour les angers7
et pour faire fleuve 5 est ce que les
blancs vont faire aussi après toujours
possible de faire des g4 que pour le
chasser mais
après ils te dh 5 des trucs pour aussi
peu cassé un peu tout ça
peut continuer comme ça
le badge et blanc soit pas moins bien
ouais bon se voiler mais oui non mais en
fait car cette chance juste pas envie
qu'ils aient le moins d équilibre quand
il fait j'ai 4 sera pour faire h3 sur un
coup comme h5
ou là tu fais rien de faire grève tout
fou d2 où j'ai pas un coup a donc bloqué
par tanger s'est tu fais ton choix f4 et
de façon five 5
y avoir
quatre fois pour ce canard yeux oui bah
en gros magnus avec les blancs veux veux
faire une turbo d'euros
je ne pourrais pas vous ne pouvez pas
contraire
donc là on repasse les coups
bas du cou structure symétrique les
dames ça change très vite
voilà
passe rien en fait en gros il se passe
vraiment rien comme on disait tout à
l'heure un seul quelque chose à faire
aujourd'hui visé fait le demi-heure
faite le
parce qu'aujourd'hui normalement ça
devrait tout est changé à moins d'une
gaffe ou d'un truc mais bon le truc ce
qui est bien plus d'enjeu sportif
réellement non plus même s'ils avaient
une gaffe bomba dans une grille aura une
gaffe pareil
de faire un top 10 des plus beaux matchs
championnat du monde a le truc c'est que
c'est long de faire un résumé dans la
chouffe la du monde à d'autres pour
faire le top 10 des meilleures parties
et à partie et ja
prendra du temps mais des matches j'en
ai pas mal hein
on est pas mal
on va dire que les gros clash
c'était un peu les passations de pouvoir
à chaque fois
le premier salut est dans mes joueurs
ont tourné sorte stanislas caire qui me
vient en tête quand spontanément mais je
dire - ses annoncé un nouveau stade qui
avait gardé son titre 3 4 x 4 fois je
pense la sq après qui a pris le pouvoir
pendant 27 ans
lascars capable en cas que blanca li qin
bon après mais malicki ne fait pas dix
matchs contre eux ils étaient calmes au
dessus qui perce quand il dit
il faut à chaque ronde quand donc il
était quand même plus fort dans kelly
quine du coup je sais pas si après il ya
d'autres matches trop intéressant après
étude à paraître bobigny qu
un peu bizarre votre vie n'est qu'un
jour il perdait le match aller gagné
votre tour donc il y en a un qui est
très connue c'est ma seconde table le
premier
il est beau ce match ouais opposition de
style ex terrain sympa prête et
petrossian qui arrivent et qui a battu
ce pépin qui a battu monica vatus
plastique et pas du groupe laski le
fameux space qui fisher et karpov
cauchemar intéressant en fait le premier
très chaud il ya cinq victoires partout
s'est joué à l'arraché quoi
puis bon autres le syndicat reproche
kasparov
ben les plus chauds ce point de 84 suite
88 85 87 ont versé 3 3 plus gros 86 or
gagne
je préfère largement mai et plus de
marche peut-être et 190 même s'ils
étaient serrés en fait karpov une
lecture trop victoire d'affilée
je crois que je sais pas fait qu'elle
soit était vraiment déjà plus forts sont
donc un peu moins intéressant peut-être
à prêter eu peut-être une question
cramique intéressant parce que
bouleversant qu'un des fêtes de 14 dans
un match n'était jamais arrivé
et puis récemment je sais pas quel gros
match on a eu ces carlson caruana en
vrai pas au niveau de la dramaturgie
mais au niveau du niveau de jeu ce qu'il
était le match le plus fort avec les
cards off kasparov un
jeu fort
niveau way à steve wallace est assez
impressionnant
et voilà
enfin je veux ta vidéo de la partie
fisher ben y en à laquelle il y en a
deux fêtes il a battu l'autre frère
et bout quoi
fisher mais un coup à l'audition
ouest partie du siècle pensait que dans
carlson sera à la retraite il va
révolutionner la pédagogie en partageant
tout son savoir non
je crois que vous êtes un peu matrix et
par la pédagogie aux échecs en fait
grand-chose à réellement inventé en
terme de pédagogie
et la révolution la pédagogie
bah non mais personne n'a juste amener
cette approche de longtemps m combat
physique dans le jeu en fait et c'est
pas la pédagogie et comment tu vas
apprendre à jouer des pièces et voulait
placer
et des choses comme ça
fait c'est même pas tellement dans la
preuve dans le cou qui joue en fait
c'est dans l' approche globale l'échangé
est aussi y avait beaucoup de
et beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'analystes d'ordi déjà dans les années
2000 karl scène un peu arrivé à un côté
un peu plus humain mais tout en
réalisant à fond avec l'ordi faire les
deux à la fois la bac et par l'histoire
dit son truc mais personne choisir les
numéros 1 systématiquement malin avec ça
on va céder son plus gros apport on va
dire et après dans le jeu bailly complet
quoi il un très bon feeling pour le
placement des pièces et calcule bien
donc voilà c'est un peu avec son point
faible quoi le sale qu'on peut un peu
détecter des fois c'est
c'est quand il fut attaquée pas trop bon
prix qui aime je sais pas maigrir et ça
n'intéresse pas trop de se faire
attaquer et peut-être que enfin ça m'a
peut-être c'est sûr il défend moins bien
les finales que ce qu'il les joue quand
il al'avantage quoi donc voilà ils vont
déjà parlé dans une finale supérieur
contre lui si simple
et voilà sinon bah ouais quand on a va
l'attaquer à l'initiative celle de peu
mal à l'aise
mais bon il cache bien ça enfin c'est
juste des gens le savent un essai savent
pas le faire c'est juste qu'il permet
pas ce que ça arrive
ceux-ci l'avantagent des prépare
aujourd'hui ça ça car tout un pan du jeu
en fait
c'est le joueur parfait pour son époque
toujours très au dessus on voit dans ce
championnat il domine
et voilà donc on verra le futur candidat
qui ça sera s'il a une chance dans un an
mais il sera une nouvelle fois favori à
sa succession va dire
oui il sera toujours favori qui a fait 4
par of et un jour il perdra les médias
soient refaites et février quand même et
voilà a perdu ce sera pareil car les
scènes
de presse qui veut pas dire qu'il pourra
pas être gagné le titre jusqu'à ce soir
il a eu l'opportunité de rejouer pour le
titre ça se trouve il a rejoué un match
en 2003 contre kramnik y aurait plus
qu'à fin je peux pas savoir peut-être
pas peut-être et oui puisque non mais
peut-être voit ça on sera jamais un
violent se prennent
perdu 1 il approchait des quarante ans
thomson encore de la marge il que 30 31
mars et intérêts
kasparov c'est fou quand même à
longévité le non plus avec un beau style
baba
c'était plus un federer kasparov et kara
scène c'est plus un djokovic fruits
qu'on le saura rien mais georges tron
sur la comparaison elle va vraiment bien
maxime maximy pourrait peut-être aller
aux candidats
voilà il va jouer les grands prix est
sorti des rails c'est un des meilleurs
joueurs dans ce format après ben c'est
pas pour autant que tu te qualifies mais
ils peuvent elles peuvent vraiment fait
ça même pas pour
pas pour vous faire plaisir ou pour dire
un truc sympa spéciaux sur la chaîne ce
qui peut vraiment quand il a toutes ses
chances mais en face il y aura de la
concurrence et aura du monde et terreur
du dink bien et deroff
je pars rognant peut-être saut enfin
bombay quant à guérir voilà quand à
toute cette concurrence là tu peux très
bien ne pas gagner enfin et finit 3e ou
peu importe 5e ou ce que tu vis titillé
par mais c'est loin d'être fait mais
c'est loin d'être impossible aussi
est quelqu'un qui demande c'est déjà
arrivé qu'un joueur ne défendra pas son
titre de champion du monde dans la
meilleure le meilleur exemple c'est
bobby fischer
y avait refusé de franck ailleurs au
physique aujourd'hui je ne peux plus
m'arrêter échec en fait mon but c'était
de champion du monde l'été ciao job de
mike
c'est bien mais ce bar
bravo
mais
l'autre
c'était liquide mais il est mort lui en
fait
ça s'est dit oui non c'est différent je
garde mes ses deux seuls en fait qui ont
pas rejoué ensuite donc normalement non
le champion arabe donne pas son titre en
général quoi
dont il je n'ai pas peur de faire pas si
l'arrêté des 72 karpov et je vais parce
qu'ils savaient que c'est à quoi sont là
mais les carpes avoir été un très bel
adversaire pour fisher ça évidemment
ben on va juste il a raté il arrêter
quoi
[Musique]
après qu'est ce qu'il a fait webb
apprend l'a plus revu 192
son match contre spassky
comme ça enfin et la première partie
qu'il a fait était vachement bien belle
espagnole et il avait un bon niveau de
jeu quoi après évidemment l'hérault
était un peu fatiguée un sais pas si on
sera les cheveux blancs moi je vois
fischer qui trop de cheveux aussi mais
ça jouer à un bon niveau quand même il
était bizarre ce match quand même oui
mais bon après 20 ans sans jouer
franchement j'ai même le simple fait de
l'existence du match étrange prix
puis surtout qu'il a partout après il
est venu faire ça et c'est toi
[Musique]
mais je me souviens c'était
l'effervescence moi j'étais très petits
champs prenez pas
dans les magazines ou quoi quand elle
est partie quoi mais ça me parlait pas
fischer en fait avec ça mais qui était
champion du monde
comme je les ai pas connu de mon vivant
c'est comme si on avait parlé de
casablanca au coiffage j'en sais rien
fait
christophe même pas une partie
est marrant pour karpov quand même ne
pas avoir plus bas de fisher enfin à
peut-être perdu 1
c'est que c'est un truc qui manque
peut-être à ce qui est aussi reconnue
dans sa carrière à bavay karpov parce
que c'était tellement un grand joueur il
n'est pas souvent cité dans les plus
grands joueurs de l'histoire car prenant
peut-être qu'il avait battu fischer il
en sera autrement là en fait c'est ça à
eux d'être qu'on s'en souvienne que le
mec qui a battu fischer pas ce qui a pu
lui en fait j'en connais qui a perdu
contre kasparov ouais c'est ça le truc à
une carte offensive
et karpov pardon
surtout contre toutes leurs parties
qu'elles soient fils a gagné qu'une
partie de plus non
quand on fait leur face à face c'est
très très chaud dans les matches
dans le premier il ya moins deux aides
après ils égalisent
86,6 doit gagner de 2 points ou
1.90 guen d'un point donc en fait sur
l'ensemble des parties à une centaine à
gagner une ou deux de plus 2 ouais je
pense qu'il a plus vrai c'est donc
en prenant en compte que kasparov était
plus jeune qu'il arrive après tout c'est
quand même pas grand flou mais
d'apporter une arme résistance et il
aurait pu 80 cadres bête humaine quand
même 5 0 après neuf parties enfin 4 0 20
ans après neuf partis c'est bon mais au
dessus en fait mais qu'elle soit
appréciée par les résister c'est
incroyable
1,85 ses shows 86 ou 87 karpov une
douzaine la dernière
dernière pratique pour lui c'est ryan
kavanagh qui divatte une victoire de ce
soir 19 karpov voilà
bon voilà il était pas loin de
10 juste parfois du tout du tout quoi
non et en plus c'est une fin vraiment
quand comptez le plus âgé et que tu
joues au temps normalement tu
physiquement tu un coup de temps qu'est
ce alors que là il n'a pas trop encaissé
mon accord ils menaient 4-0 donc après
il a perdu six points en f1 toujours
facile aussi d'enlever les parties de
quelqu'un a gagné ah bah oui donc il
nous a gagné 2 à gagnières
rosie
sa chaise on sait quelqu'un me dit
quelque chose je sais pas si quelqu'un
lui a dit soi lui-même ces violences à
se forcer à rester là et
a tenté une autre attitude qu enfin je
sais pas il y évoquait faut changer un
truc dur à dire
suncor la partie salaire égal je pense
f5 là non ouah c'est égal f5 c'est bien
h3 et j'ai
recherché
et
y avoir un conflit c'est tout juste si
square
w pions
bon je suis nulle quoi bon
alors je veux dire
ce match va changer les pauvres
écoutez ça pour du même nom mais si cela
ne change en bien c'est possible en fait
c'est ça qui est marrant c'est soit tu
as we collapse parce que voilà et on l'a
dit c'est une possibilité que je
souhaite pas du tout soit peut-être il
s'en sert
comme base de travail qui ont ils vont
en faire plus de deux il a quand même
changé son style pour ce match et s'il
arrive en fait à ne pas brider autant et
je vais en même temps un peu son ancien
style trouver le juste milieu c'est très
pertinent quoi
c'est pas je sais pas ce qu'il a en fait
il y avait quand même une épaule s'était
grünfeld nash dorff il envoyait et voilà
et là on voit il joue des petits gambie
d'amd catalan il essaye de prendre des
petits dans taisho espagnol ben ouais
mais comme personne c'est dur et là ils
jouent ça pétera fait et donc ouais
s'est il agi change en fait de style et
s'est dit que c'est ce qu'il a tenu à
faire pour réussir une chance dans ce
match ça n'a pas marché ce peut être
exigée trop déformante jeu c'est pas bon
ça peut marcher mais en tout cas c'est
clair baye mouké n'était pas obligé de
tout jeter à la poubelle et de se dire
qu'il ya peut être un mix à avoir jamais
joué mon jeu sans faire n'importe quoi
machin et
est donc
donc voilà ça peut lui servir en bien ça
peut être aussi bas chao trop compliqué
on sait pas si on peut vraiment pas
savoir en fait ça lui appartient même
lui en fait même s'il décide pas dire
j'arrête tabac d'un traumatisme et
machin ou une grande source de
motivation enfin
je peux pas vous dire
mais après évidemment on est poli a
toujours été un peu
passé fragile le mot émotionnellement
mais passons le dit avant le match qu'on
a merveilleusement bien quand ça se
passe mal ça se passe mal
et c'est tout et quand ça se passe bien
ça se passe bien on va gagner le
candidat il a pas lâché l'affairé c'est
un genre de rush quoi voilà le rocher
négatif
il est négatif
en fait ça n'a pas tellement changé dans
ce côté là
ça se trouvera guère en 2
j déroulé voilà je peux pas vous dire
c'est juste un autre monde
on va aller dans ce monde là pour savoir
ce qui s'y passait
h3
je crois que tu peux te prends un petit
h 5 qui n'a pas su pas envie que cette
grosse tension
j'avais presque des games oui et non en
fait fin
juste une idée heureux du récent titre
façon quelle que soit la manière après
tant qu'à faire si tu peux avoir un gros
combat est gagné au terme d'un énorme
combat
ce serait un truc légendaire ben c'est
toujours mieux que de gagner à plate
couture et ce qui compte c'est de gagner
quoi tu vas être un peu dégoûté pour
l'adversaire parce qu'ils se connaissent
pas mal ils ont bossé ensemble à une
époque et je pense qu'ils ont même âge
donc il s'en va voir une certaine amitié
déjà mère rallye de voir avec eux tu
connais même c'est un adversaire sur la
partie tellement aux abois quoi mais bon
c'est compte d'abord c'est gagné sarda
fume une pub qui part
ça fait du bien
cette respiration
on naïma du ci sera pas rassuré si la
fille rouge a en face
bah oui mais non mais non enfin tepa
rezaï va
le loustic déjà ici père il se dira je
reviendrai la prochaine fois je vais le
défoncer et à mon avis va essayer de lui
mettre la pression et la tête sous l'eau
direct à batz et si vous essayez de
faire ou bien sûr
non mais oui enfin juste pour cent il ya
un bon match up contre lui dans leur
score mais il a un bon score quand ils
s'affrontent mais comme sait pas ce
qu'est un bon score bon jeu fischer
aussi je veux dire ça augure pas
forcément tu veux gagner le match
d'ailleurs dépôt avait mené 4 1 enfin
bon pour l'instant vers la scène il peut
se sentir plus fort
il est probablement mais bon alors un
point dans la proche du match hoca déjà
à mon avis ya moyen
clairement il peut être dangereux un oui
john carlson spot le derby des dix
prochaines années ça pourrait ressembler
un kasparov et karpov mais je pense pas
personnellement balance ils vont pas sur
5 matchs en tout cas
d'ailleurs récemment c'était rare que
la mecque gagne deux fois les candidats
y reviendrons et yoann andreu
en fait il a gagné qu'une fois
d'ailleurs
c'est l'équivalent est ce que le père du
chat revenus et
voilà c'est déjà hyper durant donc
si on revient une fois c'est déjà beau
revenir deux fois je crois que c'est
a perdu deux parties de suite en longues
ah ouais euh
je sais pas en fait et s'il ya problème
très longtemps
franchement je sais vraiment pas très
bonne question
se passe rien
forest beaucoup 40 ont fait pour que
ça rend le type de partie s'arrêter les
mêmes la même en rapide qui dure 15
minutes c'est terrible en fait un c'est
à dire vraiment longtemps pour rien
avec 45 jean tu as vu comme ça arrive à
tout le monde mais
une bonne gestion dans tous les matchs
qu'il a fait une bonne gestion de ses
nerfs
l'instant on tient bien et c'est vrai
que si personne ne trouve une question
est-ce qu'il arrêterait quoi il avait
dit ça une fois dans une interview si je
perds j'arrête
après faut pas croire tout ce qui dans
les interviews quoi qu'il en soit ou
peut-être qu'il le pensait sur le coup
et puis confrontera situation en fait
non j'aime bien le jeu continue mais
donc ça reste une possibilité moi je
pense pas
l'amener peau
x
à partir d'aujourd'hui est spéciale
bat aujourd'hui enfin c'est
bon comme des fois je zappe de tour de
france quand il escamote
les trucs pour que pour qui et cucq pour
pas que des hors délai ou quoi ils font
exprès de bon qui on roule pas atteint
donc ça aussi il escamote la partie quoi
installer paysage tour de france
et que tu regardes le patient
a compté jusqu'à maintenant je le sac en
existe un que les étapes foule plat en
fait ça passe même pas à la télé parce
que les 60 derniers kilomètres ah oui ou
non ils se montrent pas de hasard elle
assure des seuls quand ils montrent que
l'agent de ces quantités grosse étape de
montagne
et puis c'est intéressant talmont sa
part dans les échappées machin et tout
c'est cool
pourcentage la réponse aux meilleurs et
le gâchis mof en 2014 magnus avait perdu
en 4 et 5 contre caruana radjabov tu
vois ok donc c'est peut-être 2014 la
dernière fois merci pour cette stat
est-ce que né pauvre n est peut être
essayer un baroud d'honneur aux blancs à
la prochaine quand même pas pourquoi pas
apte à son kit est la
vraie pourrait dire je fais une nulle et
mais il peut tenter un baroud d'honneur
veut comme un jacky durand
1 en france télé diffuse l'intégralité
des étapes du tour ouais mais bon après
ce qu'ils ont des gros moyens et que
tu regardes pas vraiment que l'étape de
paysages et les paysages dont les
petites histoires des gens polis
mais j'aime bien quand ce monde ils
traquent ont appelé ce qui est encore là
jean paul les histoires sur les
monuments français et c'est assez
sympathique et c'est pas vraiment
l'étape du tour de france que je regarde
mon anti en vrai
ici jean paul
put un peu de pub aussi ah bah oui
et c'est jean paul est toujours là bas
ça serait cool de l'entente nous
expliquer ces petites histoires alors
c'est franck ferrand il est pas mal
franck ferrand aussi d'ailleurs
en fait il est bien enfin c'est juste la
première fois que je change pas
tellement l'habitude dans ton de la voix
tout est petit entièrement mais franck
ferrand il est pas mal aussi
et [ __ ] les chutes aussi
il coûte bordure possible à quarante
kilomètres
il y à un vent qui souffle deux côtés et
qu'ils vont s'organiser et non
finalement il n'y a pas eu le coup de
bordure est sur le coup de bordure qui
peut partir à tour et donc à tout moment
c'est là devant l'écran pendant quatre
heures et y un coup de bordure qui par
quoi s'en fout et puis non biais des
fois oui j'en suis là c'est la bordure
là là ça va être des relais pour y avoir
des bordures pour le début du tour de
france là je crois que c'est au danemark
ça souffle au danemark et il ya un
endroit sur un pont j'ai un peu regardé
la carte je regardais pour autre chose
mais je suis tombé sur la carte pour ça
il ya un moment il peut vraiment y avoir
un coup de bordure
tente reviendra pas ici mais il peut se
perdre à toujours aller hop iommi
attaque de pierre rolland est magnifique
ça
et là je suis de thibaut pinot ray
c'est terrible astellia ya deux ans
quand site et milou il ya trois ans qui
s'était mis le coup de guidon dans le
jeu bah ouais dans la cuisse et qui
s'était blessé comme ça c'est moche
enroulé ans mettant danseuse il avait
[Musique]
juste techniques mal maîtrisées mais
s'était blessé comme ça et plus ou moins
perdu le journal
ces revers de suite et fait une question
jusqu'où
les avril guidon dans le temps 2019 une
sorte de béquille ouais
les frères schleck aussi
un
peu un beau tour de france
je suis en histoire on apprend à
mépriser ferrand 2 tce berne dès la l1
après ses débuts le gari thater 1 font
leur métier entre guillemets
peint d'après mashable com du coup je
suis pas aigri d'histoire je peux pas
trop les reprendre mais ça et quand tu
parles à des millions de téléspectateurs
bon ils sont là pour aider de vélo de
base ont tu leurs monte de trois
monuments d'autres athlètes explique en
gros ce qui s'est passé ce n'est
peut-être pas dans le détail historique
prête a besoin de moins de
plus non je ne sais pas quand
mais bon oui et c'était quelqu'un de
vulgariser évidemment tu veux pas les
blancs vouloir de ne pas tout dire après
je sais pas ce qu'on leur reproche un
petit disant n'importe quoi juste super
au courant donc disons mois voilà j'ai
pas nouveau pour la reprendre quoi
je connais pas maxime il connaît bien il
regarde beaucoup le vélo enfin il garde
beaucoup il connaît bien
vous avez
cantona bah écoute il va bien il est un
peu dubaï là elle est rentrée en france
voilà il devait participer au choix du
monde rapide et beats mais on se passera
les ou pas et
est donc la prochaine grosse échéance
sinon ce sera d'aller grand pré feed
pour essayer de se qualifier au candidat
donc il y aura deux strapontins faudra
essayer d'en prendre au moins un sur les
dauphins sur les deux points ils
pourront pas au fond d'eux les deux et à
et voilà on vous pour les nouvelles
saveurs d'ailleurs gerland tout cas
c'est un peu
quand tu fais des parties d'échecs quoi
raconter un peu n'importe quoi sur ce
qui s'est passé ça marche mieux que dire
la vérité encore que les échecs c'est
différent mais les échecs comme ça reste
un truc de niche tu peux encore faire
comme nous
un truc assez factuel mais nous on parle
pas au grand public en vrai en parle un
grand public sans parler un grand public
et de faire les deux quoi mais tu
pourrais pas raconter les parties
d'échecs pareil s'il avait un million de
spectateurs je serais vraiment obligés
de descendre d'un niveau descend d'un
niveau et je commençais à dire afin de
raconter les parties sans montrer une
seule variante oui juste dire de bla bla
bla bla bla bla des quatre il a mis un
pion au centre 5il roussillon sens
incroyable et l'effroi il attaque le
pion il le défend oui contre attaqué en
fait on vous racontera la partie comme
ça à eux quatre ils placent un pion dans
le centre c'est très bien joué il va
contrôler avec ce pion le milieu de
l'échiquier versa yen n'est plus mais
chic y répond par cinq la symétrie ne se
laisse pas prendre il ne perd pas la
bataille bataille du centre qui débute
dans cette partie et les blancs qui vont
mettre le camaïeu en f3 attaque le pion
aux 5 ici on aurait pour coutume de
continuer par cavalier c6 pour défendre
le pion ou par des six des coudes
défensif mais il ya nepomniachi n'est
pas de cette humeur aujourd'hui contre
attaque immédiatement par cavalier f6 il
attaque le pion aux 4 que va-t-il se
passer magnus carlsen qui prend le pion
au sein qui pensent comme que c'est une
aubaine elahian les pommiers chine
reprend pas on le 4 mai il va jouer le
coup des six il attaque 90 2 pièces en
même temps c'est extraordinaire ce qu'on
voit dans ce début de partie le cavalier
qui recule et iren qui peut maintenant
récupérer le pion un début de partie
très réussie fabien par yann nepomniachi
qui maintenant une pièce au centre a
magnifiquement placé au centre et on se
demande si déjà les normands pas
davantage du coup d'avoir mis ce qui a
valu au centre alors que kebede trois
blocs le développement des blancs est ce
que le russe ne ferait pas son retard
dans ce match en résistant dès
aujourd'hui mais c'est la réaction de
magnus carlsen immédiate fabien dames 2
effectue un clouage sur le cam a lieu
quatre lecavalier n'a plus le droit de
bouger un c'est interdit dans les règles
je le rappelle on n'a pas le droit de
perdre son droit aux échecs et là
stupeur yann va trouver une défense pas
bien sûr cette menace qui paraissait
déjà peut-être mettre ko le russe déjà
mené trois points oui fantastique le
russe qui joue dame satie copie son
adversaire et qui coupe le clouage tout
en défendant son cavalier sera ordinaire
magnus carlsen qui déplace son cavalier
en f4 qui vient recontrôler des quatre
centrales qui dès qu'ils débloquent des
blocs le pion le pion des de yann qui
décide de bouger une troisième fois son
cavalier dans l'ouverture et qui va
mettre les dames face à face fabien
échange de damian qui pourrait perdre sa
dame au prochain coup fabien il pourrait
mais il peut reprendre ça va être encore
le roi le fou qui protège donc grosse
tension entre la dame qui va craquer à
prendre en premier
le champion du monde ne craque pas il
met un nouveau pion au centre avec le
pion des deux qui arrivant des quatre
coups de développement de yann qui sort
le cavalière s'est si ce n'est une
pression sur le pion mais le champion du
monde impérial jusqu'à maintenant
continue de parer les menaces ils jouent
ces trois fabien il renforce son centre
vraiment du grand art il voit toutes les
menaces et pour l'instant il est sûr
qu'une brèche dans son jeu les noirs qui
vont réagir maintenant par des 5 il
bouge son pion une deuxième fois mille
mais dans ce cas est central fabien le
combat est intense les deux joueurs vont
se développer le cavalier qui part en d2
le cavalier noir qui va dès maintenant
en des huit une case bien bizarre et ce
qu'il a une idée derrière la tête fabien
ou c'est simplement une faute c'est vrai
que c'est très étonnant en voyant voyons
voir la suite pour voir ce qui va se
passer pour mieux comprendre ce coup de
retrait du cavalier quoi c'est
impressionnant cavalier f3 est la leur
u500 petit à petit crack et c'est lui
qui lâche en premier la pression il
prend en a eu deux et donne un coup de
développement gratuit aux blancs à ce
moment là de la partie on voit quand
même beaucoup de pièces sur la huitième
un ranger pour le joueur russe et on se
demande s'il n'a pas complètement perdu
la tête c'est possible afin qu'ils
fassent vraiment attention pour faire
son retard de développement dans les
coûts à venir
c'est au noir de jouer qui va faire à
bay hill se développe il fait fou des
six bravo très belle réaction il se
prépare peut-être à faire le petit rock
c'est magnus qui va jouer ce coup très
spécial des échecs c'est le seul coup
fabien qui permet de bouger deux pièces
en un le petit rock et à ce niveau il
est effectué dans quasiment toutes les
parties celle-là ne déroge pas à la
règle magnus carlsen qui fait le petit
rock et réaction immédiate de gagner
premiership petit entretien il s'en
laisse pas conter toute solitude et leur
rock aussi les blancs qui vont toucher
deuxième fois le fou pour l'année
jusqu'à la case d3 une belle diagonale
il y a une qui prend premier la colonne
ouverte avec la tour mais magnus s'en
laisse pas conter par email à tour tout
de suite pour réagir alors attention ne
fait pas ça c'est le cas il n'est pas là
pour défendre la tour mais tout va bien
le champion a bien tout prévu n'y aura
pas de maths du couloir d'ailleurs yann
et ça écrème de fer spot du couloir mais
magnus reprend il couvre et maintenant
il va jouer ce cavaillon aussi une idée
diabolique de yann qu'il avait prévu un
bien acheté donc ça l'idée d'arcade et 8
du film en parfait pour mettre le
cavaillon réussissez venir chasser ce
cavalier f4 qui menaçait le pion d'un
des cinq mais qui était défendu les
blancs qui vont échanger car l'allier
prend fou prend g3 pour empêcher le mag
du couloir femme miral cause de fuites
bien jouer les noirs qui font une case
de fuite et maintenant magnus carlsen
qui se rend compte que la case g2 est
libéré et il en profite pour mettre le
cavalier petit coup de bol ici pour pour
magnus à fabien oui ça tombe bien ça
tombe bien il avait plutôt misé pour
éviter les maux du corps pour être le
roi mais finalement ça tombe bien le
cavalier pour profiter pour venir ici
peut être rebondir vers le centre alors
il ya une qui voit que ça tourne à 8 2
joue pas en profite pour la mettre en 1
8 reprendre le contrôle de cette colonne
les blancs qui joue f3 ou san mames lui
c'est un petit peu pataugé fabien
dagneaux parti il fait des faiblesses
vers son roi peut-être il va le payer
très cher voyons voir la suite le
cavalier
noir qui part en cinq jeux va-t-il faire
on s'est pas trop un cavalier sur le
port qui ne contrôle plus trop de cases
je crois que c'est une stratégie qui est
élaboré par le champion français maxime
vachier lagrave de bien placer les
cavaliers au bord de l'échiquier et la
réhabiliter cette manière de jouer qui
était plutôt décrié jusqu'à présent un
magnus carlsen qui en profitent pour
centraliser son roi paroisse f2 il est
en finale ils sont que le roi ne sera
plus en danger il va l'utiliser comme
une pièce offensive c'est du jeu
vraiment très très précis en finale
fabien les noirs qui vont jouer ces six
qui vont renforcer le centre les blancs
qui envoie g4 et magnus carlsen qui si
avec ce coup de pions qui ne paye pas de
mine va créer une menace effectivement
attention les pions prennent un
diagramme sur les côtés et donc le
cavalier se retrouve en danger donc le
fameux le fameux cavaliers mvl qui va
devoir se replier et tout comme magnus
carlsen coup de chance la casse g7 est
libre c'était une case pour le roi mais
finalement lequel il faut y aller dessus
on souffle côté côté russe un magnus
carlsen qui maintenant va vouloir
développer son fou pour pouvoir sortir
sa tour il va le mettre sur la case f4
ont vis-à-vis du fou des six est là
encore petit coup de bol avec ce
cavalier g2 qui protège ce fou et ça lui
permet de se débarrasser du fou de cases
noires à ce qui était très dangereux et
donc ils l'imposent un peu cet échange
car elle prend aux cavaliers prend
vianne qui maintenant réagi pargesa tout
de suite il ne perd pas tant ra taxe aux
cavaliers qui était très fort et manu ce
recul alors peut-être qu'il a pu prendre
le fou on ne sait pas tout cas il a
choisi de garder ce cavalier en vie il
se replie et il ya nepomniachi qui
passent à l'attaqué qui passent à
l'action il envoie maintenant son pion
f1 f5 pour venir menacer le pion g4 et
ce pion f qui est défendue par le fou et
encore ce satané cavaliers qu'est-ce
qu'ils sont bien qu'à passer les
cavaliers angers 2 et angers 7 donc
probable et influent kétou du cavalier
pour les plus avertis
qui défend ce pion pion qui renforcer
immédiatement par le coi h33 f7 le roi
vient lui aussi au centre et tourache un
fabien un court qu'on a du mal à
comprendre la tour qui vient se placer
derrière un pion c'est vrai que là c'est
peut-être trop subtil pour nous
la tour étant un levier en h1 peut-être
qu'ils anticipent une prise angers 4
pour reprendre du pillon ce qui pourrait
être bien l'aider peut-être pour se voir
la tour sur la colonne h
mais pour l'instant bon genre risquent
peut-être pas intérêt à faire cet
échange donc il va jouer un coup là
encore un petit peu mystérieux h si ce
n'est peut-être pour renforcer son pion
et magnus carlsen qui décide de
maintenir la symétrie on voit que c'est
symétrique
côté pion à l'ale dame ça ne l'est plus
à l'est le roi il va rétablir cette
symétrie par le coup f4 et voilà où on
en est les amis dans cette partie
extraordinaire pour le moment ah ouais
la tension est à son comble qui va
remplacer mettrai en première qui va
craquer
voilà on va on peut expliquer les
parties comme ça
c'est trop bien
youtube comme ça quoi
un peu de montage mais bon
l'événement une tâche de type
d'exactions mort certaine
mais bon après
dès qu'on disait est ce qu'on a vraiment
vu ça ou pas quoi
raconter ça change
ouais
après le truc c'est que
en vrai c'est de la caricature mais les
contenus ressemble de plus en plus à ça
en fait ouais malheureusement ou
heureusement
c'est triste mais au niveau je comprends
mieux avec cette explication t'as rien
expliqué en fait on
met des mots et on dit des choses qui ne
sont pas exacts mais qui permettent
d'expliquer quoi
rixe et qu'il faudrait tenir deux heures
avec vous mais non mais là c'est pour le
résumer on dirait que c'est un comment
tables en fête une partie comme ça ce
qui se passerait rien de chez rien de
chez rien mais pour les résumés wii
fit statut
jusque
bah oui en vrai on pourrait demander à
lille de faire
tanguer officiel l'annulation
est en faillite ce sera pas au
kazakhstan
se fit des workshops rapide and bridges
and then she will not be held in
kazakhstan in december grandement neuf
cases avec stone and the case that she
knows what you want dance is caused by
this cancellation
de wheeling
nationaux newbie destruction son clip
blablabli et blablabla
tu imposes sept jours de quarantaine
pour tous les véhicules peuvent faire la
quarantaine ce qu'il va faire de
quarantaine c'est honteux reach impose
monde attend lui sa van dyke routine for
many potentiels participants making la
participation d'une possible solide
contre effective des zones authority de
juin at been expanding over the past few
days la fidh examine urgemment des
alternatives ah ben c'est pas encore
fini c'est pas plus de gagner mais c'est
un deal au kazakhstan
ils cherchent des solutions de
remplacement et en essayant de donner
plus d'infos d'ici la fin de la semaine
quand ils font ça on sait qu'ils ont un
autre plan b en lettonie par exemple
au devoir du tour h 7 kg cet essai fouda
nuit à chaque fois pour éviter les
quarantaines cas ça me rend fou et
puisque genre l'open d'australie cette
année ils sont laissés enfermer un
jeu mais c'est fou de voir que les gens
fassent des quarantaines fin c'est la
règle c'est la règle
des règles
bon ça va là ça à faire la drew bress
voit plus trop tarder vraiment le
droit explosé là si on a fait comme ça
l'analyse de la partie
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
sarde
et qui c'est qui fait ses dessins en
fait
et qu'ils disent oui mais peut-être que
ce qu'on peut faire c'est juste encore
ans normal
nul insipide qu'on va vous raconter
jeu lors des personnes a pris des
risques soit l'année où on peut être
trop un
spoiler je sais pas
j'ai peur qu'on puisse pas le refaire
une deuxième fois aussi bien en fait
aussi
ouais c'est aussi plus d'un pro qui
a mis à part l'analyse avant finlande ya
rien à dire en fait
avaliser la partie c'est juste qu'ils
ont échangé sur les pièces en fait enfin
si on la fait normalement on va la faire
aussi mais ça a duré huit dix minutes et
ya rien de spécial à dire ouais
on reproche on faire ça d'heure mais
en fait
c'est juste un match de foot où il a
passé à 10 ans 90 minutes enfin fait
faux pas à s'inventer de live c'est de
la merde en fait maintenant mais a pas
d'autre mot en fait c'est juste liquide
tu sais il n'y a rien à voir c'est nul
en fait aujourd'hui oui en fait le truc
soit parti bah ça dure c'est clair ça
fera deux heures de jeu il aurait pu
faire ça en 15 minutes
justice aurait bien sûr de paga fais pas
tu fais un rapide compte des retombées
sur internet il faisait ça embête au
tour de xavi dont je suis grand
bonhomme accès c'est pas en mode sa
fadeur fois arrêté regarde ce que tu
regardes en fait enfin
il est pas content d'y rester le sommet
c'est pas le seul face à un parti
c'est fou de par comprendre ce que vous
voyez en fait
non mais je sais pas en fait c'est pas
comprendre je peux même pas expliquer en
fait mais en fait juste en fait on n'a
même pas mécontentes soit passé comme ça
c'était attendu qui étoit boudreau et
ben c'est ce qui s'est passé c'est que
ça échange ses chances télécharger puis
voilà vous voulez 40e vous saurez faire
nulle où ils vont répéter il y aura plus
rien sur l'échiquier
mais c'est de la panacée tout en fait
c'est de la place à 10 soit donc tu vas
pas dire qu'il va est extasié devant le
maintien
vous c'est ça quand je disais qu'ils
escamote les étapes c'est roule à 20
alors dans la plaine et tu regardes ça
toute la journée tant les paysages
et sans doute est ce sens et pas de prix
qui a il escamote tout
il n'y aura pas de bordures y aura rien
s'est il ya pas devant
légère brise peut-être
pas de pluies vont pas que ça glisse non
plus tout va très bien quoi
c'est vraiment après non mais moi j'en
veux pas du tout aux joueurs ou quoi que
ce soit c'est pas assez passe à la
question c'est juste que ça à zéro
intérêt
alors que je prends des petits coups d'
échec échec
en finir
ouais
c'est bien triste spectacle sur ce match
mais question c'est comme ça
à tence joueurs norvégiens tente un
piège quand même surtout réfute pour
avoir une fourchette angers 6 attention
[Rires]
t
parce que je suis content car c'est là
où il a quand même
là je crois qu'on est pas beaucoup à
perdre c'est dur de perdre mais bon à
ces divers de faire
après répète pas les coûts plus vite
ouais franchement ça c'est un truc que
je comprends pas je suis fait un clin
d'oeil il veut être bien sûr reste peut
faire un clin d'oeil juste arrêter sa
faim ça aucun intérêt pour personne en
fait quand même long pour la page de pub
du coup oui il magnifique parade à ils
ont tenu pendant la petite page de pub
les demi heures
terrible
ce génie de la pub
aussi ce que
je vais essayer de faire annuler away
voici je cherchais une nulle sympa aussi
ça peut peut-être cavani aussi si tu le
laisses faire tour f7 tu fais ton g8 du
geste le cavalier il faut être fait fort
et fuite qui change de sûr
ça va tu souffles
la veuve noire mais là ça va s'arrêter
d'une seconde à l'autre en fait pas ou
par imaginons encore ça pendant deux
heures
c'est beaucoup
rien à dire
art situation ouais
ouais je comprends qu'ils réfléchissent
mais c'est tellement bizarre
les deux joueurs dès le premier coup va
le faire annuler en fait
ça donne des parties très étrange
or un petit 6 le cavalier bouge
qu'il peut faire kf4 pour faire une fois
que j'arrive pas à comprendre c'est
qu'ils veulent faire nul mais pas trop
fâché pas quoi expliquer
ce que juste fait cavalier la
forme et le carillon f4 erpent 8,6 l'a
bien compris et je sais pas pourquoi ils
font ce truc de je veux faire nous mais
pas trop alors que tu veux faire les
fruits il ya un truc que je que je
saisis pas en fait
soit tu crois
si le match est à 0 0 je comprendrais en
fait mais c'est juste vu tout le vu le
score du match fut le coup en fait je
comprends pas trop l'intérêt
je propose pas nulles ben faut faire une
capture du coût 40
des gens pour des cons non pas du tout
c'est tout ce que je vous l'expliquais
juge je comprends vraiment pas ce qu'en
fait ils veulent tous les deux vers nous
et ils ont les moyens de le faire
mais ils le font pas je comprends pas
trop pourquoi
je sais pas si c'est pas plutôt je vais
faire mieux mais je regarde y'a pas les
opportunités un nom à un regard la
position en fait juste
marais ya pas trop de rossoni t1 s'est
vraiment symétrie qui a plus que des
pions sur un côté et pourrait faire
n'importe quoi pour pour perdre c'est
toujours positif et une énorme gaffe tu
te prends une fourchette ou tu laisses
ton rêve cette rencontre cet emprunt 7
mai les vertes wife 6 du coup
on doit plus tours
est surprenant si ce qui est probable si
ce nul sera le coût 40 c'est très bien
pour faire nous peut-être qu'il a
calculé ça ici c'est le coup car entre
possible aussi
je pense pas qu'ils la jouent beaucoup
rené pauvres est venu à trois points de
retard ça n'a pas de sens
en fait ça a dû calculer ça
ouais bon voilà un petit nul ça va
s'appeler non plus trop longtemps
bekaert scène qui compte 6 points et
demi encore deux comme ça il sera je
suis gardera son titre aujourd'hui rien
de spécial à dire que vous avez vu ça a
beaucoup échangé
un nul logique et
de les deux valeurs les deux joueurs
voulaient faire nul en fait honnêtement
ils ont tous les deux obtenu ce qu'ils
souhaitaient
et donc est ce que je veux dire il reste
il restera deux parties probablement
donc demain non demain ce jour de repos
on va bien soufflé souffle
alors bon les centraux souffler un
chacun d'autres trucs à l'événement tout
en beauté mais moi j'aurai les matins
avec société générale j'en reparlerai
peut-être sur twitter vous verrez il y
aura des montées qui viendra du coup
pourquoi on te met du temps à l'académie
et moi le soir je compte aussi sur tous
comme fr le speech le carreau nassau
voilà donc il y aura plein de choses
encore de ma fille laura la domination
voilà
bah écoutez bonne fin de journée voilà
on vous l'hiver on retrouve sur youtube